[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so for the past
month I've made the commitment to drink
a lot more water to be honest my water
intake has been absolute rubbish and I
do struggle to drink plain water just on
its own so what I've been doing is that
I've been adding chair feeds into my
water and the benefits to my body have
been incredible it gives me the energy I
need to get moving throughout the day
here are a few fun facts chair actually
means strength in the Mayan language it
is also known as runs food because
runners or warriors would consume them
as few while running long distances or
doing battles before we get into the
chair water recipes here's what this
superfood actually does for your body so
it's acids are naturally low in cost and
high in fiber just two tablespoons of
chia seeds provide you with 11 grams of
fiber which is almost half of the daily
recommendation now because of its high
fiber content it can absorb up to 10
times its weight in water becoming
pudding-like and expand in the stomach
when eaten which keeps you feeling
fuller or longer
hence it is often recommended to those
of you who want to lose weight cup epic
size and reduce your food portion the
high fiber content will provide you with
sustained energy throughout the day and
if you can finish at this prior to your
workouts it can boost your performance
up to 90 minutes so instead of grabbing
those sugar-laden sports drinks replace
it with chips instead
chasis are ranked amongst the top
plant-based source of protein on the
guttering fatty acids and calcium so
just one serving of justice contain as
much calcium as a glass of milk more
iron than a cup of spinach more omega-3s
than a serving of walnuts and as many
antioxidants as blueberries so consuming
chia seeds on a regular basis will help
you to get all the essential nutrients
and minerals that your body needs so you
can make these child drinks you
coconut water green tea fruit juice or
even coffee simply mix in about 1
tablespoon of chat feed to 2 cups of
liquid of your choice then let it sit
for at least 15 minutes or overnight for
the chia seeds to fully expand if you
want to you can either sweeten with a
little bit of honey or maple syrup add
lemon slices or lemon juice or ice cubes
and enjoy them chilled these chea drinks
are just like the bottle children you
can find in stores but hey they are way
cheaper way more delicious because you
made them so these are just a few ideas
which you can try out do experiment with
your own flavors and make your shower
water drink them on a regular basis
every day ok if you consume these on a
regular basis you will feel more
energized it will increase your workout
performance you will have a better skin
health
a better digestion and it will also help
with weight loss so let me know which is
your favorite flavors in the comments
below try this recipe out share with
your friends and get them to drink a lot
more water ok subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot of new videos and
Dusan on the certification button so
that you will get notified every time I
share a new video all the best